[Music]
directive
[Music]
[Music]
there are so many cobwebs like my wife's
womb
you're not the first one to say that
jorge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's no time to argue throw me the
build bars
you have no choice
hurry
you stupid [ __ ] he's mine now
oh no dr jones
the competing bar is the little poison
that's putting it mildly
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
delicious delicious sip but just the
right temperature too because everybody
knows good headphone volume i was just
talking with dave as we were watching
that intro yeah if i was if i happened
to be running from a boulder and there
was a face level spider web
that's just it and i'd be run over by
the boulder
you just turn around at the jungle
you're like that's
webb's from here i'd go in just once
with a machete and
then throw it yeah
and be immediately eaten by snakes
that's better than spiders kidding you
you know what's funny by the way this is
before i get to and have that admonish
button ready today because i have
something i need to uh admonish myself
for all right uh not afraid of snakes
water snakes scare the hell out of me
yeah because they don't belong there
they don't belong there you're not a
fish you're a snake and they swim like
this with the head up
i don't understand you're supposed to
you're supposed to be horizontal pick a
lane yeah that's lochus monster stuff i
don't care for it exactly
so i don't know i don't know what they
are copperheads water moccasins you guys
can let me know but the point is i would
be fine if we just eliminated every last
one today we are going to be talking
about mitt romney is a piece of human
fecal matter uh and before anything else
admonish me right now admonish me
admonish me admonish me i deserve it
because
i voted for that [ __ ]
what yeah what what against barack obama
maybe maybe you need to that's i guess
i'll do it twice we really missed out
now
[Laughter]
we were so wrong but so did the hajj
twins it was the only choice at that
point come on him or barack obama
uh talk about holding your nose
had to do it for a while so my question
to you is is he is is mitt romney the
worst republican
is he the worst rep that's it and if not
if not him who is and if he's not just
the worst overall politician i don't
know maybe aoc but he's just as bad yeah
because at least i know where i'm
standing with aoc i mean i don't know
where she's looking but i know where i'm
standing yes
she's smiling at me there's two of me uh
with mitt romney i just he's never had
there's never been a single issue that
on which he hasn't held two positions so
we'll talk about that also i don't know
if you know this but in florida they are
actually trying to we were told they
weren't trying to sexualize your kids
and then uh teachers started quitting
amass because they can no longer
sexualize your kids so you do the math
but before we move on to any of that
look if we are not doing a show if you
don't see us here on youtube especially
when we're discussing you know the
pedophilia stuff right which is a thing
uh youtube doesn't like it though you
can always go over to rumble so monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern we are
streaming live
rumble or mug club we have another uh
our show today where we are doing a
reddit review of this amazing threat
it's going to be a classic of a
man whose transgender girlfriend uh is
taking birth control or wants to yeah
there's a deer oh boy
yes there's a lot of
real questions to be asked here abby
back in the day would have responded
gross
you just hear a gunshot
you're like is this off the air now yeah
uh all right so before we move on to any
of that uh gerald a how are you sir i
was better before we had that segment
introduced for today a lot of fun i'm
okay i've been up since uh three oh
really yeah we got the little ones uh
little ones and they were you know
they're doing their whole thing but uh
it's fine
yeah no sleeping sleeping it's little
ones what'd he say
yes
all right joe and you know uh you know
him you love him i am going to be with
him at the tulsa ballroom on may 14th in
tulsa oklahoma you can go to
lydeworthcrowder.com the two of us
together uh there are some tickets left
very very few very few
which actually sucks because we have a
really funny commercial for tulsa
tomorrow we may just have to cut i did
all that sam elliott work for nothing
dave landau how are you sir ahoy how
about you i'm fine i love you wearing
your ed furlong white supremacist jacket
yes that's what i do i got a strange
animal though there you go yeah i want
my brother's in jail yeah exactly but
the thing is he does laundry with a
black guy and they bond that's how he
figures out that he's not racist yes
exactly he's like no
there's a guy who pretended that a
pillow case was a clan hat right yeah
exactly oh that's why you stopped oh
okay that makes sense yeah you're easily
swayed what was the scene like where you
told him about the the curb stomp yeah
we never got that never came up no he's
like why are you in here and i was like
oh nothing nothing it was just a it was
a you know misunderstanding yeah
embezzlement long story short i uh beat
a guy at basketball which wouldn't have
happened and then
no no i beat him at basketball with you
know the big guy from my name is earl
yeah yeah who's who's now actually very
athletic but at the time was not
all right so before i move on to that
we're gonna be talking well it's almost
all gay because you have you know we're
talking about the florida bill yeah the
reaction and mitt romney
so and this is the uh before that uh
i've been instructed not to watch this
and this has been circulating everywhere
it's a commercial for oreos i believe
and they said don't watch it my
producers because they wanted me to
watch it on air this is my life
unfortunately
sorry and so uh and now yours have you
seen this yet dave i did
cheated i i found a guy who peeks at
christmas presents i i found it actually
because i was quite stunned
and i had to say guys we should show
this to stephen as you were eating oreos
i picked once at a christmas present and
i found out what it was and it ruined i
was like i never want to do that again
you know what it was it was a power pens
with a z you guys do you guys remember
those like a pen that shoots a dart and
mine was supposed to be a spy pen where
you could hear people and it would
amplify it but instead it was just
just a bunch of feedback it didn't work
well if this was a christmas present
most dads would be like boy i wish you
would have got me something else yeah
hey do we still have the box tell them
to play and it will put them in a fridge
out on the curb
one of those classic uh kitchen aids
yeah that you can't open from the inside
when i
lock it oh those aren't good no they
aren't no problem in detroit yeah all
right so this is a commercial for oreos
i'm watching it for the first time uh
apparently i'm alone in this let's see
what they're doing
oh no are they going to beat him with
that no
right
oh no we're i think i know where this is
going
i've seen enough gillette commercials
sure
it's the best man can get well
[Music]
i need
well that's nice
i don't know what the fuss is about so
sweet
no i
oh you're ready oh no see i thought he
was talking to her at first that's what
i thought nope i ordered a nice little
tail there's a guest look who's coming
to dinner
or guess who's coming
you're
i mean right so much it's the remake of
guess who for the third time
oh i just saw the way that guy walked
that i think i know where this is going
it was a little bit of a
stelter yeah
at least it's directed in the most
horrific like korean cinema way yeah how
is this a commercial yeah exactly all of
a sudden there's gonna be the host yeah
how is this a commercial what is this
this is a commercial
this is a uh yeah it's a commercial a
very long commercial but a short film
commercial as
oreos
[Music]
good old hum sing yes
[Music]
best song ever
coming out doesn't just happen once what
the f okay
oreo
when you're hiding what's on the inside
my gosh
oreo because we're cream-filled yes
i know that that's the look it would be
a more appropriate commercial for bob
dole to be literally screwing his 90
year old wife
a viagra
it could just be two men railing each
other and then it's just like pop charts
yeah exactly
and then it's just you know it's like
another guy jordan then like pop-tart
mini bites i've just never been at the
store and been like excuse me are these
el fudges lgbtq friendly right yeah
you're frosted mini wheats i'm the wheat
side and i'm the queer side yeah ah oh
well good i can support this
excuse me dude are these oreos ex do
they like gays yes you know i'm sorry
what the oreos do they like gay people
could you get out of my store oh let me
pull there's gotta be hey anyone here
gay yeah do you like oreos might as well
slap it right on my hips this is false
advertising yes they don't like these
yeah make sure you get the name brand
oreos the off-brands hate queers
yes
the westboros
[Laughter]
you drown them in milk
you don't just dip them you hold them
down for 60 seconds exactly
uh
let me drag them
[Laughter]
they would have a problem with the color
of the oreos as well oh my gosh i just
that's okay that right fine that's just
well no more oreos advertising oreos
used to be the close to perfect cookies
well you guys will you guys no longer
buy oreos does daily wire need to start
a 100 million dollar cookie company yes
an anti-oreo company i don't even care
it's i like oreos it's just we're just
pandering that's what i hate about all
these corporations if it wasn't if it
wasn't hip to be gay you wouldn't be
doing it no no not at all yeah where
were you going nine years ago yeah
seriously i don't remember the aids
epidemic 1985 oreos do you
just follow your stores yes yeah exactly
show me your saudi arabia commercials
i'd love to see if it transitions over
there
count chocolate was just magic johnson
yeah just losing like 90 pounds yeah
he's just like barely like holding on to
the cereal bowl
i frosted philadelphia flakes okay
where's frankenberry oh he's not on this
yeah he died
he was waiting on some drugs at night
was a long
painful death it was drawn out we can't
figure it out all of his friends
sam is just following his nose to mexico
to get the real cocktail jared letos
[Laughter]
all right gosh
well that's good i'm just glad that we
all know what cookies are for crying out
loud i just can't believe that this is
well i can't believe it yeah totally can
and then people's act like people act
like you're crazy that you think they're
trying to sexualize everything yeah it's
a cookie yeah it's a cookie that just i
mean it should
there shouldn't be any sexual i didn't
know that gays weren't allowed to buy
oreos no i there's someone just blocking
them like no no no no
and then finally they were like all
right
we like you now yes
this is the official policy of
albertsons if they saw a gay man buying
oreos to take that dividing bar
hey these aren't for you
[Applause]
i'm sure hands off those cookies the
astroglides aisles over there sir
i think i know you're kind all right the
bananas are over there right i want to
pick up some condoms for your deviant
lifestyle yes exactly
also i don't know the directions to the
bath house
about you where's the bathtub okay
so here's an update yesterday we talked
about this elon musk yeah uh you know
ninety nine nine a nine percent stake in
twitter which makes him the largest
shareholder yeah and we have an update
uh that as of this morning he's also
he's taking a seat on the board of
directors yeah taken a seat on the board
i love how park here taken is the right
word yeah he just there was that what's
what's your name that shirav virgin that
lady whose name sounds like the lady
parts who was on joe rogan oh and he's
like
the soup thicken looks free yeah oh it's
mine now what are you doing no we should
get along your table it turns out i own
this place
so weird weird flame throws a table yeah
greed is good so he was welcomed
enthusiastically by twitter ceo agrawali
and he said i'm excited to share that
we're appointing elon musk to our board
through conversations with elon in
recent weeks it became clear to us that
he would bring great value to our board
no elon chimed in he did
yeah see this which i like
it's like when jeff goldblum in life
aquatic walks over and spanx bill
murray's dog yes
uh elon musk responded looking forward
to working with perog and twitter board
to make significant improvements to
twitter in coming months i like how he
tweets like he's latka from taxi yes oh
my gosh just to add that extra level
thank you very much yeah so i think
seriously had a conversation where they
were like yeah elon's gonna be great we
have to put him on the board well this
will allow him to have an active role by
the way in things like you know the band
user accounts tweets that have been
suspended for example you know and
they're all those death threats made
against me people posting my addresses
yeah and uh peop posting my address on
twitter like no i'll leave it up
i don't understand the rules like you're
not supposed to no no no so he'll he
should actually have some
well he should have the ability to
influence policies at twitter yeah i
don't know if he will
uh i'm hoping he's that guy yeah that
guy who gets power and actually does
something good with it he seems like it
so far yes he does yeah and of course
the uh the uh the uh the the gestapo uh
the the left they're they're furious
especially your favorite guy mr robert
wright robert reich i'm not going to say
reich or rishi's definitely the clearly
threatened i guess by what this may mean
do we have his yeah yeah what could
possibly go wrong with an oligarch
determining what constitutes free speech
don't you love how we went from the left
you always used to use these arguments
we would talk about youtube or facebook
or twitter for example with the new york
post story or us quoting the cdc being
banned so yeah it's a private company
they can do what they want
this is too this is too important to be
in the hands of oligarchs right that's
exactly so only elon musk is the
oligarch yeah and by the way his version
of free speech is hey uh stop banning
stuff right so maybe yeah his version of
free speech is actually called free
speech yeah it's pretty crazy you should
look it up sort of like his version of
green policy his version of you know
renewable energy was actually creating
products that people wanted as opposed
to forcing in men like california which
he had to leave
think about that for a second
that you wanted that'd be like a nazi
being like i guess i have no place in
deutschland anymore no
i miss you
i'll have to go over to america the
train starts running on time
i'm the loneliest nazi
[Music]
[Laughter]
no more juice
no chamber to pull the switch
i will miss you germany
exactly
i look forward to seeing i just can't
believe that elon musk had to leave
california in other words if green
policies worked yeah come on it would be
it would be uh shangri-la for someone
like elon musk and he's just like wow
this real we really i cannot do this in
california you should love his success
but robert reich and those guys only
want it to be successful if it comes
from the government or mildly successful
the minute you start making a ton of
money off of something and going
gangbusters with it they're like oh
you're part of the problem now yeah
unless you're in the government man i
don't you don't want me to be a part of
the team got it well it's because
capitalism and the constitution is a
real problem for these people it really
is well they openly hate it that's
really like oh the founding fathers are
racist here's one thing too
when people try and say uh or just as
american as you are no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no but you're
talking about wanting to break down
institutions and norms well that's
because it's patriarchy okay but let's
let's just say that that's let's assume
that that's true and it's not white
supremacy paycheck okay fine well guess
what those are the institutions of this
country so let's assume that they're all
bad and of course they're not but if we
use your argument you still hate this
country there's no way around it i just
want to improve it not if you want to
fundamentally change what makes this cut
it's like i like oreos really i just
think it should be chocolate chip
cookies well you don't like oreos yeah i
love the constitution except for you
know serious parts of it yeah i just
want to change most of it namely the
main points of it yeah
you know there's stuff that makes this
country great i just want to get rid of
that part just bring that stuff out
they're like well if you look at the
comma on the second amendment right to
bear arms okay so what's your solution
no right to own guns whatsoever oh okay
that seems a little more extreme how
about free speech there
not entirely so much so uh here's
another story before we get to mitt
romney and this is gonna be fun uh a
six-year-old man received uh this is in
germany sixty that's what i just said
you said six
i didn't say six
six
can we have money
there's no such thing as a six-year-old
man just like there's no such thing as a
six-year-old transgender that's the
whole point of me saying 60.
thank you for making my point
six-year-old transgender we'll get to
that there's no such thing as a
six-year-old transgender if you can't
consent to sex and you shouldn't you
can't consent to sexual reassignment
surgery period
okay done
all right a 60
year old man
received up to 90 injections oh wow of
the covid vaccine
uh
in order to sell fake vaccine cards with
real batch numbers
[Laughter]
so you have to appreciate his commitment
yeah i mean they're not even really fake
cards no not if that's just straight up
i mean there's some buy-in yeah at that
point you just let him have a card i
mean he's doing that's
he's
doing uh satan's work so 90 injections
you know what the worst part is
91 injections
90 seconds free really just shy oh
that's too bad did he have the little
punch cards
yeah it's called his it's called his
tricep
so uh
according to ap it's not immediately
clear what impact the shots which were
from several different brands had on
this man's personal health although we
actually do the video of him uh taken uh
this man in question 90 coveted vaccines
just before the time of arrest
well you know i i'm not i'm not a
biologist also his wife uh
is suspected of taking a similar amount
of
vaccines which i think yeah oh well you
know well you know what you know i think
uh vaccines might be good for women
after all yeah i encourage any uh
attractive woman to look into it yeah
attractive and or busty yes especially
busty yeah
is this you can be one or the other it's
best you be both
yeah is this a cry for help from this
guy he's like yeah give me another one
let's use the j and j i hear that one's
really effective yeah
you got any of that uh astrazeneca in
there it's like yeah it's right next to
the packing penis he was basically
vaccinated from the vaccine at this
point
who knows what's going through
synthesize his blood
okay hey brother oh i forgot so the
intro uh this show to you uh today is
brought to you by builtbar you can go to
build.com use the promo code crowder15
you get 15 off your next order uh i've
been using them the built bars you know
since i lost about 30 something pounds
yeah they just use them like dessert no
one needs like protein they're delicious
although built build bar we got to talk
bar we have to talk real talk bring back
coconut fudge brownie chunk and i the
name's long
i get it
but it was the best flav it's the best
one we need to start a campaign the not
just the coconut one i don't want this
with coconut put it back
i want the coconut with the fudge
brownie chunk what happened
i don't need any more birthday cake
it's really delicious
it's fantastic stuff yeah the coconut
brownie chunk was it a limited edition
was it seasonal
what are you getting it from local
coconut brownie chunk farms is it like
the mcrib
[Laughter]
or the shamrock shake
this is from the coconut brownie chunk
farm to table uh built bar no it was
delicious i love those i put them in the
freezer it was the yeah
they're all good all the chocolate ones
but that was my jam okay now it's time
to move on to uh and i've been waiting
for this for a while and i don't know
why it took so long uh mitt romney what
a piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
all right so we have uh a few
reasons here as to why romney is just
the worst and you know you probably know
what happened just recently but does
anybody like me comment below did you
did you vote for mitt romney and still
you know what you know what hold on a
second
before
i want to hear from the mormons yes
beca and i i get because
you know how when like terrorist attacks
happen well there aren't enough there
aren't enough moderate muslims like
condemning it across
mormons you need to condemn mitt romney
you guys owe us we do it with the
westboro baptist church yeah we're like
well they're not there's like only 12
members and eight of them have flippers
they're all brother and sister they're
not that so mitt romney you know because
he gives unfortunately a lot of people
go like oh look he's mormon i don't
think he's actually really mormon
what i think he's a scientologist
i kind of feel that way too wait why and
his full name mittens yeah i know oh my
gosh
like a cat i don't even think he's a
person all right i think he's a cat in a
people costume cat cat self that's this
is just mittens that's the fact we
should just dangle a piece of yarn out
into the ocean yep see
he's a cat in the people constantly what
i don't know
oh
do i like yarn do i not like yarn i
can't decide
he's pro yarn and then he's auntie young
he's really anti-yarn today
so a few examples of he is the
quintessential example people talk about
uh elite politicians yeah uh people talk
about the swamp this guy is a career he
comes from a family of no i don't just
mean wealth but he comes from a family
of politicians he's been in public
office for a very long time uh what he
did with bain capital was very different
from starting a business from the ground
up right you are sort of talking about
that
what people
basically going in and laying people off
is what he would do now i understand
that that's that's something that
efficiency experts do i get that i
understand it but it's not the same as
starting a business from the ground up
right so uh a perfect example of
how shitty and just so if you have kids
that you should have been tipped off
with what a piece of [ __ ] segment the
word's going to make a recurring
appearance
as to how shitty he is this is a perfect
example of how out of touch with the
average american is when he made the the
two cadillac flub
i like the fact that most of the cars i
see are are detroit made automobiles i
drive a mustang and a uh and a chevy
pickup truck ann drives a a couple of
cadillacs actually and uh
uh i used to have a dodge truck so you
should have all she's riding them like
skis yeah just she's got a couple
caddies
he just basically said yeah we have five
or six cars that we just rotate between
like oh wait a connect and we put our
dog on the roof of all of them yes
indeed
we have two cadillacs in every garage in
this country that's the american dream
and then we have a dodge ram in the
driveway and then i also have a tourist
show
there's a couple mustangs he's trying to
name every american for private jets yes
i also have an audi i'm hiding i love
the two nissans yeah tesla's good too
yeah
anything else made in usa that i own i
never drive them though that's my
chauffeur
he says he loves them yeah and i have
nothing against if look i think it's
great if you have wealth if you've
accrued wealth i think it's great if you
have cars that's fine it's just this is
a guy who never understood how out of
touch he was with the average american
and now let me kind of parlay that into
the american voter i don't know who he's
trying to appease mitt romney
i i i don't know i don't understand like
this is a man who has no home he should
be homeless
he deserves no home so in 94 and in 2002
of course mitt romney
was
there was at here you go was adamantly
pro abortion pro-choice is that we're
each entitled to have strong personal
beliefs and we encourage other people to
do the same
but as a nation we recognize the right
of all people to believe as they want
and not to impose our beliefs on other
people i believe that abortion should be
safe and legal in this country i have
since the time that my mom took that
position when she ran in 1970 as a u.s
senate candidate shannon snack a little
extra point in there that i want to
address and that is with regards to my
views with regards to protecting a
woman's right to choose and i've been
very clear on that i will preserve and
protect a woman's right to choose and
have devoted and dedicated to honoring
my word in that regard now here's the
thing if you hillary clinton that
wouldn't be a problem okay right but
here's why such a piece of [ __ ]
is because you can feel free to when i
sit with yeah you know that's that's
your cue we don't want to
we don't want to misuse
the sound board
respect the sound board
um
he then flip-flopped you know he said he
changed his position in 2004 and his
telling of it was he met a medical
researcher working in embryonic stem
cells which is entirely a question he
was asked about it i believe in the
primaries in 2008
there was never a flash of genius moment
and i don't believe him let me tell you
why i don't believe him it would be one
thing if he said i was radically uh you
know pro-choice and i was you know as a
democrat for a very long time because i
didn't understand the science and then i
uh became you know i converted to
mormonism or i converted a christianity
and through my faith i did some more
research and i realized that i was wrong
okay that but he didn't said he was like
i was i was pro-abortion and then uh you
know uh no i'm not what a piece of [ __ ]
that's the issue yeah he basically
licked his finger put it up in the air
and said which way is the wind blowing
on this issue for my uh my voters uh the
internet came out and he was like oh
i'll do that right yeah
and then he was like oh wait does the
internet does the internet also mean
that they have the video from all the
times i said that before
yeah i was shown polling recently that
said people would like me more if i held
this position so you know what i hold
that position but i also read polling
that said
people will never like me
they will never like what i do do they
also have uh uh videos of me in private
crapping all over poor people oh dear oh
my word my stars
boy
that almost makes the two catalog uh two
cadillac seem like what am i joe biden
right now is that a stroke i just
thought that's because he has two
catalogs of cattle he has two catalogs
of cadillac he just looks through his
own catalog why'd you have a catalog of
your cars printed yeah oh i do you don't
have these you don't have your own
romney wish list and it's just your
garage i'm sorry you don't have no you
must be stupid and poor yes
you can't understand this you please i
understand you're gay do you like oreos
yeah
how about doritos now here's
a real oreo eater twix
oreos twix doritos you're taking my will
to live
those are yeah kit kat stay out of it
yeah come on lucky charms need to change
the taste the rainbow
tag no that's skittles
yeah i think they're staying neutral i
think they were always a gay candidate
that's what they throw out of the gay
pride party yeah which is not safe
because it's not you know it's not even
packaged at that point just loose
skittles even seagulls are like this is
a little hard to change
and i eat fries covered in cayenne
pepper now uh
do you both
no it's like seagulls i used to used to
cause i used to eat the fries oh yeah
cayenne pepper and then i realized it
was cruel
i was a kid
i was a kid i was a child you were 27
well i'm just kidding
that's second adolescence so in both
impeachment proceedings against uh
president donald trump uh
mitt romney and he was one of the only
republicans and again it's just it's the
constant virtue signaling with this
piece of [ __ ] that's the problem with
mitt romney it'd be one thing if you
were a democrat i understand it
but it's another when he claims to uh
he cl he claims certain values he claims
shared principles and then he never
stands on them consistently
and he wants to say hey everyone look
hey aren't i great look how inconsistent
i am yeah people are like that just
makes you it just makes you a dick he's
like i prefer piece of [ __ ]
so
he voted
for impeachment two times here you go
here he is talking the grave question
the constitution tasks senators to
answer
is whether the president committed an
act so extreme and egregious
that it rises to the level of a high
crime
and misdemeanor
yes he did
the president asked a foreign government
to investigate his political rival
the president withheld vital military
funds from that government to press it
to do so
the president delayed funds for an
american ally at war
with russian invaders
you're talking about juventus purpose
was personal and political
accordingly the president is guilty of
an appalling abuse
of public trust okay first off
first off we are all children yes
second he's talking about donald trump
and uh ukraine and by the way zielinski
said everything that guy said is
[ __ ] he said there was no quid pro
quo zielinski's it's not true this is
not true so mitt romney is up there
grandstanding and isn't it rich where
he's like he did this for political and
personal purposes right you've never
done anything for political gain mitt
romney of the romney political dynasty
yeah like moving to utah right so you
can run all right hillary yeah he was a
detroiter for a long time right it was
detroit
and then you know
anywhere where there's
money well where he can be voted into
office now here's something else even
for democrats uh this
would it wouldn't be considered extreme
but even now democrats will look back on
it with shame i don't know if mitt
romney is capable of shame
because you know he's a sociopath so uh
march 15th 2022
he vote this is not that long ago i
don't know if you know this
this is just a couple weeks
ago he voted in favor of keeping the
federal mass mandate on children just
like even when he stands nothing to gain
politically because at that point people
like we were wrong about that romney's
like no look i'm still dumb
you don't need a mask law for children
there's plenty of way they're kids
they'll believe anything you can scare
the [ __ ] out of them in so many ways yes
exactly drop it already you know it's
unreal when i still see this and instead
let's uh spend that money on getting
them estrogen pills but here's mitt
romney voting uh in favor of it
next we have braun amendment number
eight well now interpreting hhs from
implementing or enforcing their
regulations regarding mask or
vaccination protections in the head
start program again i will be a no on
this
does anyone want senator braun's 15
seconds
seeing none
clerk will call the rule
by proxy
senator romney
romney he sucks
she's almost looking at him like romney
are you gonna
no
really all right
now here's the thing the most recent one
of course you know this just happened
yesterday uh uh romney or yesterday or a
couple days ago was it on april fourth
was on april fourth what are we the
sixth day no we're the fifth we're the
fifth okay so romney uh he did he came
out and he said that he would be voting
to confirm uh former vice president
biden's radical uh supreme court nominee
uh katanji brown jackson
now
and that's that shocks some people this
shocks you for very good reason so
here's the weird thing
he voted against her and i say her as in
a woman
he voted against her when she was
nominated to the dc uh appellate court
yeah long long time
yeah well in 2021 oh 2021 yeah oh
so i mean like there's almost no new
information right could possibly be
available hey everybody come and look at
how not racist i am yeah
sure i was months ago right but i've
changed my way since december mitt
romney is the only person on whom whoopi
goldberg's reverse psychology work it
absolutely works you're not gonna vote
are you racist child no i'm mormon
define her no one can do that how dare
you and people always go well no one
else was ever asked that well you know
why because everyone else throughout the
history of mankind would have been able
to answer it
it never came up no it never came no one
ever had exactly no one was ever like
can you tell me what a woman is and
somebody was like i have no idea right
exactly and the reason it wasn't asked
was because we didn't have men competing
and winning in women's sports now i know
what you're saying when you say men what
do you mean i mean male with a penis in
the pool with women yeah saying he's a
woman yes because he believes it because
he is yes
never crossed their minds that there
would ever be any debate and and some
people are trying to argue this is just
gotcha no no it's relevant because you
will have cases that will get kicked up
to the supreme court and by the way the
legal definition of woman matters at
this point for things like title ix by
the way
for uh sexual abuse laws just to be
clear
of course it matters it didn't used to
matter because no one thought that woman
would just be a figment of your
imagination or it could be anyone who
chooses to put on a maxi dress that day
mitt romney what a piece of [ __ ] that's
i'm done with this guy
[Music]
by the way if you're watching right now
you can smash that like button because
uh i don't know if you know this
mitt romney hate watches this show does
it and this will just reflect to him
they don't like him
stupid mittens stupid i'm so glad that
felt a little that felt good did it feel
good it did good i've been angry at this
person for a while good so yeah i feel
better about forum
all right now we move on to uh you know
the whole uh don't say gay bill oh yeah
can't say that word yeah hey you know
here's the thing you can't say gay but i
i tested it did you i still can really
yeah yeah i traveled to florida just to
see if i could and i just i landed in
florida not southwest because it was
canceled yeah so i landed in florida and
i said people misrepresenting a bill by
claiming that it's titled don't say gay
even though it doesn't appear in the
bill well that's gay and no one arrested
me
how did you escape i'm just saying you
have to test you have to go through the
scientific process or just you know read
the bill right yeah exactly that's that
would be it might have been easier but i
needed a break i needed some me time
oh i get it
um plus i had to ask all the roller
skaters in miami about the don't say gay
bill and you know what they you know
they were just they were very handsy now
bladers they're supposed to be called
bladers yes
for that purpose alone yeah they're
trying to rebrand yes
they don't like to they don't like the
term fruit boots
[Laughter]
okay um
so
i'm trying to think of how to get into
this but
all right we'll get to the point of all
these teachers now who are quitting in
florida because they can't actually
indoctrinate your children uh with the
whole sexualization and gender theory
but over the weekend huffington post uh
published an article written by uh
allegra hirschmann i think i'm
pronouncing that correctly but you don't
need to tweet me uh allegra i don't care
so i say you're named after allergy
medicine yes exactly no oh sorry wait
that's a typo it's zyrtec here schmidt
oh sorry clarice and hirschmann yes
don't get me struck yeah
i'm gonna be starting on benadryl
goldberg old lownaise hirschman old
antihistamine smith
her name's my name too so wrote this
whole article uh huffpo titled i'm
trying to raise my kids as homosexuals
and i never even have to say gay now in
the article there are a bunch of quotes
all references are available at light of
care.com like this jim at first i
thought this heterophilia forced on kids
was disgusting until it gave me the
fantastic idea that i could also raise
my children with a preferred sexual
orientation from the very beginning of
their lives although i am bi my wife and
i chose to go full-on homo with your
kids and let me tell you i think it's
working now in case you didn't realize
that this is a satire it's satire and it
obviously it's it's so we're at the
point where you may not know that it's
satire because most liberals reading it
upvoted it right away
and
that's
it's like they're stealing the babylon
beast no exactly yeah i just think we
can't do it so she goes on to say that
it's satire which is a sign of good
satire oh of course yeah yeah i have to
tell you that i'm joking yeah exactly
like it says at the in the opening
credits of of uh naked gun that it's
parody right an airplane you do the same
you explain a joke and that makes it
funnier right yes it does it absolutely
does get out come on you broke that
habit don't get back into it
so here's what she's trying the point
she's trying to convey that the idea
that teachers are going to influence
your children you know as far as sexual
orientation as far as gender as far as
even introducing these subjects may be
in ways that you may not deem to be age
appropriate that it's a boogeyman right
that it's a strut that it's not actually
happening um and here she goes on to
make her case and i will uh
i will piece by piece
show you why it's entirely incorrect and
let me just sort of try and break it
down because she's claiming that it's
satire but not really because she goes
back and forth between trying to make a
point in satire just a horrible writer
this zyrtec so
i wrote this piece as a satire to make a
point thank you for clarifying even if
my wife and i actually spent every
waking moment trying to force a quote
gay agenda on our kids they may still
turn out straight oh the horror like 99
of humans always but that's not what any
of this is really about oh hold claritin
that's exactly what this is about
it's why you wrote this yes it's exactly
why you wrote it kids are easily
programmable because they're stupid
they are easily impressionable and
they're dumb
and you
well i don't know you uh i don't think
they'll be programmed by your writing
but certainly the public school teachers
can be programmed by people outside of
the home they're sponges capable of
learning everything and you're supposed
to teach them and guide them right
that's the age they're at for the same
reason you don't use naughty words when
they're learning to speak you don't
teach them about suturing up your hooch
and putting on a fake strap-on when
they're six
is that nine when you're supposed to do
that yeah i i i watched captain planet
when i was a kid and i spray painted a
fur coat
yeah yeah yeah tell me the kids are
unimpressionable well they're trying to
impress their parents too so if your
parents are pushing something your
teachers are pushing something on you
you're trying to adopt it and impress
them well and here and kids are very
impressionable let me give you some
numbers here really quickly so you've
heard me mention the fact that um that's
not what she's saying is of course the
opposite of what the data shows us now
here's the thing you may not like what
the data says you may want to say well
it's more nuanced than that this is
something we'll talk about i think next
week you know they'll say white
supremacy or they'll say patriarch
you'll hear this from the left right
they'll create these big umbrella terms
like white supremacy that's why black
people aren't getting these loans you
know from banks and you go what about
the fact that black lenders actually
give to black borrowers at uh they
reject them at twice the rate of white
banks well it's more complex than that i
know but you said white
supremacy so you're the one who's being
reductive to a false degree there's
nothing more reductive
falsely than white supremacy than
patriarchy these umbrella terms that
they use and then when you call them on
it they say well actually it's a it's a
it's a little bit more nuanced okay look
you may want to claim that and i
understand that there can be sub points
here
but the data is the data you may not
like it but it is
you may not think that data do what it
do but it be
so that's deep uh you've already
mentioned the number before where 97 of
kids uh who claim they're transgender
actually uh grow out of it and we have
the references available at
lightworkcredit.com after being uh or or
not taking puberty blockers
that number drops to zero percent so
almost all of them grow out of it and
then if you put them on puberty blockers
or you have some kind of an intervention
that number drops to growing out of it
zero
now legitimately people
complained about the stat that uh and
say well the sample study is too small
and that's true i believe the study was
conducted in either 2008 or 2011 uh
now that's because back then transgender
wasn't a thing yeah it wasn't a thing
you can go back and watch an episode of
it's always sunny in philadelphia i
believe it was season two where they
have an entire episode where a guy is
dating a transaction the term
transgender didn't exist you had
transvastites and you had transsexuals
then they just said well let's just make
a wide enough again umbrella that if a
guy a guy in a moomoo is the same as
someone who goes through sex
reassignment surgery and now we have a
third
category just to be cl just so you
understand that's why the sample size
was small well now we have a larger
study from 2021 which the largest sample
of uh uh boys referred for gender
dysphoria and that's a whole other topic
the way they've changed the definition
of gender dysphoria uh an average uh age
of eight years old okay at the time of
diagnosis eighty-seven point eight
percent were uh were classified though
okay
uh
or classified stories to sisters by
their early twenties meaning they grew
out of it we're out of it
87.87
with a much larger study so we went 97
with a small study and now at least 87.
let's just split the difference we'll
even get we'll give you 90.
can we that's an a like oh well my son
uh played with barbies because he wanted
to look up their skirts it doesn't mean
that he wants to be one yeah he also
might want to burn their hair yes
of course
i did yeah i didn't even my neighbor had
him yeah well we lit all of them on fire
you put them in the easy bake oven see
what you can do yeah and also ken he was
our here he was a post-op yep that was
post-op he was also a little bit of a
poser ken yeah not not very authentic no
so
the point is uh they try and say well
kids are not easily influenced by
teachers and this is why parents are the
are the most important safeguard just to
be clear against teachers in public
schools first off parents you i don't if
you're sending your kid to public school
you have a serious problem
in 2022 i'm just going to say that's not
an option at this point parents
if you want to raise decent children you
cannot put them in public school you
guys can comment below if anyone if
anyone just agrees with me there used to
be the argument oh i want them to
socialize i want them to become more
cultured no no a culture of degeneracy
yeah and a culture of indoctrination by
the i don't and you know sometimes
people say uh teachers real heroes
one i'm referring to them public school
teachers i actually use the term worst
among us
employees with uh lots and lots of
breaks yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh wait
you mean you work more than 182 days a
year yes
yes
there's so many pissed off teachers
right now look if you're a great teacher
thank you but most of you are not well
how do you
you kind of need the the summer though
at home to be like look you're not a
girl tim right yes exactly
it takes a lot of convincing yeah some
people circle back try to fix all of the
things they screwed up during the year
it's like i have a seven-year-old and
we're talking about eight-year-olds you
don't
i can't imagine like i'm a girl you're
just like no you're not shut up yeah no
no no no the teacher's going to be you
can be whatever you want yeah well
especially if the teacher is one of
those gender bending blue-haired lesbian
queer genders pansexual because she's
like well no actually let me show you a
picture of my wife it's like look okay
okay professor scissor sister we don't
need you to be in charge of our
children's education let me give you an
idea as to
uh how it's increased the percentage of
the population now to be clear
throughout human history there's always
been about two percent of the population
that's been gay okay that's not
something that really has changed and
we've had that data for a long time the
greatest now we can just yeah the what
the greek skew the number the greeks
just keep the numbers the greeks went a
little far with it well the greeks were
it was as far as same-sex sodomy were
100 but it wasn't it was a power thing
it was exactly yeah yeah they didn't
want to do that yeah dominance yeah
exactly
how long you're going to be out at sea
yeah right
how do you establish a pecking order
yeah come on
learn to speak greek we're going out
fight battles
so let's go by generation though this is
from gallup okay not a bastion of
right-wing conservatism uh those
identifying as i love how they use the
term lgbt some of the q-a-a-i-p are
gonna be pissed off yes they are so uh
born before 1946 0.8 percent then baby
boomers 2.6 percent then gen x it goes
up to 4.2 percent then millennials it
goes up to 10.5 percent then gen z is
20.8
and some projections they're estimating
that it'll be 50 that means it's a coin
toss it's heads or dicks yep
heads or heads or dicks or tails yeah
now i understand that there's a certain
portion of society who you know the rock
hudsons of the world you know where it's
like they said no i'm straight but
secretly they were you know playing
doctor with gomer pyle so i get it that
it wasn't as societally acceptable
back in the day and so you would say the
percentage was higher sure but not 20
let me give you okay a couple of points
here well everybody knew though i mean
you had like liberace going on carson
and then he's like so are you uh you're
still a lucky bachelor he's like yeah i
just haven't found the right woman yet
yeah and we all just played along yeah
it was a little higher or like when
ricky martin was interviewed by barbara
walters yeah i think and she said what
uh where do you find yourself most
comfortable he said in between the
sheets with a woman with a woman yeah
with a a girl lots of women mmm breasts
love them seeing how like stelter's wife
is no yeah yeah yeah i love breath uh we
share a purse so
a couple of things um
first off
gay was still even if you say it was
less societally acceptable we can go
back to the 50s or the 60s okay whatever
yeah at the time it was still a thing
though yeah it was still people knew
what gay was
okay you didn't need a new category
people saying oh i want to keep
i want to keep it secret that i am
gay
transgender wasn't a thing in 2010.
it's an entirely new category so so the
measurement back then still would be
someone if they're trying to keep it a
secret it still would be are you gay and
back then they would have filed lesbian
under there it's always been a
significantly smaller percentage of the
population than men that's it's been
relatively fixed it's very very low the
boom and lesbianism is only recent it's
a recent phenomenon throughout history
it's mostly been gay men don't
necessarily know why we just know that
that's the case and the data reflects it
it is what it be but you didn't have to
create an entirely new category and
educate everybody on actually i'm
transgender or actually i'm pansexual
actually i'm genderqueer actually i'm
gender fluid these are new categories
and that's also why you see the numbers
going up and it's a way to normalize
everything other than standard
heterosexual relationships i'm not
saying that people should be ostracized
but it is abnormal in that it is not the
same as what has historically been the
mean the average since always yeah
and i certainly don't think it's a
healthy thing for society for it to be a
coin toss
as to whether a kid
is going to be uh you know a
i didn't want to say heterosexual a
non-lgbt there are what how many genders
now we play the game on mud club you
name that gender flag and it's not even
a joke and we can't name it there's a
two in it now yes they're just they're
just coming at really good things and
look honestly i mean kids need guidance
they don't need you to tell them that
every single thing that they feel or
think is accurate because it's not kids
want things that are always going to be
bad for them right they want food they
want to climb stuff my son right now
wants to climb things that if he falls
from which he will it will hurt him very
badly as a parent am i supposed to be
like no you can totally climb that when
he can't no of course exactly you don't
let him climb timmy no what timmy that's
true more of a mounting yeah well yes
gross
so it just shows you how these numbers
change and by so so that you'd have to
create a whole new category also
remember we were in college this is also
this is the fact that it's hip to be gay
right now so a lot of people want to say
or hip to be lgbtq aip and now they get
to claim it without the commitment right
you should just be you're like oh man i
really wish that i could be in that
niche but nah i still can't get past the
wieners i still can't get past the penis
that's kind of my sticking point
but now you're just like oh i'm just a
gender queer and i was like really yeah
i can like women or men like what do you
like today women the answer is always
women you're like well how are you queer
you're like well i don't know what
happens either tomorrow
no one knows what tomorrow brings has it
ever brought gayness it hasn't yet but
i'm still queer
i just want to be cool so when we were
in college if a girl said she was bi it
usually meant she was trying to be cool
a guy said he was by he was absolutely
gay 100 yeah because
yeah that's just
he didn't want to if it's like two guys
and a girl in the middle it's just gay
sex with somebody who knows your secrets
yes
exactly
and uh yeah that's why you know she's
got a big mouth and also here's the
thing there was an incentive for girls
to be no i mean that's they don't want
them talking to them no that's what yeah
i don't know
dukes we don't
do lacrosse teams all right we get it
this is a now i don't know how to dig
myself out but the point is this in
college a girl who said she was bi like
oh i kissed a girl and i liked it like
oh maybe just means she's open-minded if
a guy would say he's gay most women go
yeah
well yeah because they're not attracted
to that no that's the reality well
they'll go shopping and talk like long
conversations but that's what they would
do with a girl they just like the gay
guy because he's not as
[ __ ] talky
ah
they're pretty cool they're pretty catty
bunch yeah they really like being catty
oh they're a woman yes
well they're not that would be
transgender well i know but i don't know
they're feminine
the point is they're feminine
but they're not transgender well they're
just gay
there is truly nothing wrong though
and it's always been this way in society
a woman can teach a woman how to be a
woman a girl a guy can teach a guy how
to be a guy there's nothing wrong with
that that's exactly what you're supposed
to do you can look up to your father you
can look up to your mother if something
changes in your life and you are
somebody who's gay and that happens
through puberty and whatever that's fine
be who you are but there's no reason
that this should change during childhood
and be forced on kids the fact that
we've had to have this discussion so
many times is absurd and you made a good
point yesterday when you said you know
what i didn't know in school my
teacher's first name no i didn't and i
thought about that because it made a lot
of sense because i'm like yeah i
actually didn't i didn't know who they
were married to i didn't even know what
car they drove because if i did you know
you would have keyed it yes so it's like
you didn't know anything about your
teacher yeah well i just played the odds
and i keyed every toyota corolla in the
parking lot
yeah you got it our timer was a tourist
wagon yes yeah with the bubble window
it looks like the jetsons the seats
facing out the back so you got crushed
by another car
you know so here's the thing it's not
just huffington post and i use that as
an example because it's obviously very
silly and
miss zertek is a horrible writer so it's
fun uh of course be nice you can
criticize the writing don't go over to
this person's twitter and harass him i
know you guys are all better than that
but it's not just huffington post the
satire is no longer satire there's been
a slew of media figures um figures
who've been claiming that the the fl the
parental rights bill in florida
right they would say it has nothing to
do with indoctrination of children that
actually that actually never happens
just like huffpo but here they are
saying it what what message does this
send to gay children uh their parents
you know what what do you say i mean
this is your state miami okay i'm i'm
very upset about this first i think it's
not a necessary bill of course you are
is that a necessary third brunch first
graders are not having a curriculum that
teaches sexuality i am a parent a gay
parent um and i have 13 year old twins
and so seeing what's unfolding we're not
talking about sexual orientation gender
identity first to florida republicans
you're pretending to solve a problem
that doesn't exist there's not a mass
conspiracy of kindergarten teachers who
are plotting to teach children to be gay
this is one big dog whistle you're
scaring people into spewing hate and
discrimination at the lgbtq community
lgbtq
is that the baseball that hit him
between the eyes yeah
sorry sir i'm doing my best yeah
so this side looks a camera one and this
side camera too yeah exactly they're
spewing hate he just permanently sees
two red lights like oh my god the
demon's staring at me again those are
just the camera lights stop it oh no i
can't legally drive no more
[Laughter]
so here's the thing if and let's assume
that that's true gay children i'm sorry
i mean just that word is the duck cause
you just picture like a little kid who's
a little off right you're like nice gay
child yeah exactly why would that even
be a term no i know anyway sorry well
this is what they want to be a term they
say transgender youth you have the
president of the united former vice
president of the united states saying to
parents uh affirming your child's gender
is one of the most important things you
could do nope
disagree
and i don't really want to go any
further than that disagree move on move
on down the trail that's it no i don't
think so affirming my child's gender
particularly if it is separate from
his actual gender right
yeah and by the way this is because
gender and sex are interchangeable now
they are yeah they used to say they were
separate but you can't that argument's
no longer tenable if you're allowing
biological males to compete with women
because they're transgender well now
you've just claimed that gender and sex
are exactly the same thing because
sports are separated by biology not just
sex
weight
age we have weight classes in sports
like wrestling or in weightlifting why
because we separate for biological
differences and advantages we separate
for age groups it's not how do i
with what age do i identify
we separate men and women
by biological sex and people say well
the term is men and the term is women
that's because again back in the day
they just go back to it's always sony in
philadelphia in 2006 2007 where the term
transgender didn't even exist man meant
man woman went woman it's this clever
little grammar trick that you guys tried
to play
but you know what
we're not going to let you so teachers
really don't inject this sort of thing
right doesn't exist it doesn't exist
according to joy behar and anna navarro
the reply used to be a republican oh
really yeah we didn't know you the first
19 times no we could it's quite an angle
yes that's quite a really work
yeah go for it
um
if that's the case then why are so many
teachers are quitting but why are so
many teachers in florida or across the
country so distraught
over the bill that doesn't affect them
do i
lie
and
not talk about my marriage yeah do i
pretend i'm single
no do i invalidate my spouse's stance
as a trans femme person how about you
teach them
or do i put my job on the line
to introduce myself i think it's just
like omaha beach none of the above
what am i supposed to do i don't know
dress like owen wilson
[Laughter]
i don't know being a safe person and a
safe place for kids that don't have that
at home is one of the best parts of
being a teacher we're a shirt that
doesn't say that
i don't know fire me sue me okay
i'm doing it i was a preschool teacher a
drag king and as a member of the lgbt
do i feel about the nude legislations
for like the don't say gay bill or
the reporting of transgender kids
and while i don't see things like that
too much in preschool
my opinion on it or in preschool is the
correct word not too much care what the
government tells me to do it's all i am
the whole thing is white women from the
beginning trying to be a minority does
anybody else notice this
that includes mental health and safety
and emotional health and safety of my
kids mental health is that that is that
i feel like in my classroom feeling
unloved or ashamed for who they are
it all you know it's very rich say uh
almost never in preschool the answer is
never unbelievable it does not exist in
preschool
this is yeah this really sounds like a
you problem [ __ ]
this is the best sting operation ever
every single person who comes out in
favor of any of this stuff that we've
just seen immediately fired from being
teachers yeah thank you for raising your
hand and telling us that you have no
place around my kid yeah you're saying
take me to jail though it's like what
are you talking about i'm gonna take you
to jail you just don't have a job
anymore go do something else
do i still have tenure no what about the
bennies no
maybe you should just quit be a martyr
but they're in preschool
what why would you teach him anything
it's like he built a statue of you it's
like can you color inside the lines also
do you want to keep your penis
with those kids are doing the
thanksgiving turkeys with the hand and
one's just five dicks yeah yeah that's
not how it works johnny
i see you snapped your crayon in half do
you need to talk about something do we
need to get rid of no no little little
uh little carl he didn't want to do the
hand turkey he wanted to do the penis
turkey why that's not an option yeah you
shouldn't stop oh thank you yeah you
don't allow it why it's called being an
adult you're the adult in the room
they're children
you don't need to fill them in on your
personal life
and this is the thing
they assume these teachers
they believe that it is just as
important
to inform the children
on their personal life uh personal
life's activities as it is to i don't
know math
they think that you are equivalent in
their job as a teacher that's why i will
say this there are good teachers out
there yes they are few and far between
most of them unfortunately are this
right now and if you look at the voting
records and you look at where the
teachers unions give their money it is a
racket do not send your kids to public
schools if you send your kids to public
schools and more importantly here's
something that's really scary when you
when you look at the projections where
they say hey it'll be a 50 50 shot if
they're lgbtq aip i don't give a [ __ ]
about the acronym but they say it's a 50
50 shot you know in 20 years from now
well here's another interesting
statistic it's mostly religious people
mostly conservative people who are
having kids how is that happening
parents start doing your job you think
well you know we go to church on sunday
guess what
those people you just saw have them the
other five days of the week yeah for
eight hours
well an hour and a half at church isn't
going to override that it's also not
conservatives that just you know pass
along colorado that you can hack a baby
apart like it's ancient rome right yeah
exactly
good point i mean it's sadly true no
it's sadly true
way to be a downer dave well i'm sorry
nine months as a human being i don't
know how else you want to look at that
of course well you know what hey we're
three months away right now i can feel
every i mean i could feel it before i
just feel everything by the way your
wife wanted me to tell you stop feeling
her stomach well no she likes it not
while she's sleeping oh well that's no i
didn't so especially when you let us in
to do it yeah i don't know
right can you feel it kick if you do and
if you do let us in get a quieter camera
we don't need a vintage polaroid no
that's true turn off the flash
okay all right that's a compromise see
this is why we're all still friends
we can find a compromise so here's the
thing uh and don't worry to the leftist
because we know there's a good amount of
leftists who watch this show there
really are they're actually a good
amount of classical liberals who watch
uh as far as leftist progressives
probably none
if the super bigoted you know florida uh
teachers uh don't want to uh
i don't know look the point is there's
always new york they're the beacon of
progress and we're partnering with with
wpp
uh to put up boys and major markets
across florida
to let everyone know that we're
targeting fort lauderdale
jacksonville orlando tampa and west palm
beach
we believe we're going to get about five
million impressions and they're going to
be up for an eight-week period period
celebrating the diversity
and acceptance of new york city uh we
will show this in the billboards and the
billboards uh you have here right now
very clear statement and we're proud of
it other folks want people to hire
really well we like to show isis members
running the
we want to remind everyone uh that new
city is full of people who will who will
be celebrated
now and in the future and by the way
clearly he's in line with the mainstream
uh black americans opinion yes but two
genders
[Applause]
[Laughter]
preach let him go
there wasn't even a pause from the
audience no they were just like yes of
course like why are you always coming up
with this funny [ __ ] is that
what was the billboard right there bring
up the billboard again
i just wanted to read it come to the
city where you oh where you can say
whatever you want so instead of
increasing police funding so asians
don't get killed in the subway new york
city is using their tax dollars for the
okay
perfect sense yeah make sure you put
those up around the country you can save
your money in new york for this make
sure this is the hill you die on say
whatever you want like there's an asian
push them in front of the subway yeah
exactly
the only way he can stop you is he's
like wait wait get get get get like oh
oh
hey oh careful this guy's got oreos i
thought you were just asian my bad where
you can say whatever you want by the way
you can also piss wherever you want in
new york so you know what they're pretty
open about
the locale rules that's what i loved
about walking around to new york was
throwing away my shoes every day yes
exactly
if only you could throw away your
nostrils
that's totally true
this is look this is one of those this
is one of those issues where
okay and we've we've had on this show i
think it was uh we had i believe it was
jesse hurst was the first transgender
mayor of a town in texas we had uh
obviously we've had blood white in the
show many times we've had at least four
or five transgender individuals on the
show and of course people who advocated
for you know the modern sort of gender
theory on the show over over 10 got to
be a dozen you guys can go through the
archives going all the way back to
probably 2014.
and they used to say it was a straw man
they used to say well no one's talking
about children we're talking about
consenting adults and now it's assumed
by the former vice president of the
united states that uh children can be
transgender so now it's assumed that
they can be transgender again they can
make decisions
yeah that permanently affect their sex
lives before they have the ability to
consent to any sexual activity that is
now assumed as a baseline and now
they're saying well don't be absurd
no teachers want to teach your kids
about that uh you want my kid to already
be able to get gender reassignment
surgery i think we're past that
don't what you think that i'm somehow
fearing the more extreme and that the
transgender professor who has pushed for
laws the transgender public school
teacher who has pushed for laws that may
have my children taken away from me if i
don't put them on puberty blockers you
think that i'm being insanely paranoid
in believing that that teacher
may want to indoctrinate my child
you can no longer make this claim the
left no longer gets to make any on any
of the lgbtq aaip it used to be oh the
westboro baptist church and there are
four members for crying at least to try
and paint the entire conservative right
let's take the most radical position of
the conservative right you know the same
position that barack obama held the same
position that every single president
held outside of donald trump coming into
office just to be clear where they
thought marriage is between a man and a
woman you may disagree with it but that
was the extreme position marriage is
between a man and a woman and most of
these people most of these republicans
at this point in time
said of course they can have civil union
and property sharing and for example
writing someone into a will in hospital
visitations but the definition of
marriage is a man and a woman that was
seen as radically hateful
but today the mainstream view of the
left as just espoused by the former vice
president biden of the united states is
children
can affirm whatever gender they want and
by the way they can't answer a follow-up
question okay how many genders are there
they couldn't possibly answer that
question because my god they may be
forced to run for supreme court seat and
sometime in the future and that's a
political liability so if anyone else
youtube i don't care if you don't like
this this isn't this isn't denying
anybody's existence this is
acknowledging the reality of statistics
as well as medical outcomes and it's
something that with which we need to be
very prudent leave a comment hit the
like button because we're about to do
reddit review and there is
no way no
absolutely no way
we would do this on youtube so youtube
piss off
[Music]
you